There are about 1.5 billion cows
on this planet.
That's one cow for every
five people on Earth.
We keep them for dairy...
and meat...
and they’re a climate problem
that we've struggled to solve.
Every year, each one of those cows
is estimated
to release up to 220 pounds
of methane...
mostly when they burp.
That's about 4% of all greenhouse
gas emissions that are warming our planet...
from burping cows.
You've probably heard
a few solutions to this
like trying to convince people
to lower their beef intake...
or switch to meat alternatives.
But instead of trying to convince
billions of humans to change their diets
some researchers are focusing on
the diet of the cows.
And a promising solution might
come in the form...
of seaweed.
This video is presented
by Delta Airlines.
One of the reasons cows produce
so much methane
is because of their specialized
digestive tract.
It allows them to digest
tough plant material
like grass, hay, and other vegetation.
Their stomach consists of four compartments.
The largest one,
the rumen
acts sort of as a storage unit where
food can sit and ferment.
Microbes in this area break down the food
using a process called enteric fermentation.
This process provides the animal
with the nutrients and energy it needs
but it also produces methane as waste...
and the cow burps it out...
which makes the Earth
a little bit hotter.
Here's the thing, though
methane is literally waste...
and changing the diet of the cow
can change
how much of it is produced.
Foods like grass or hay
stay in the rumen longer
and produce more of it.
Whereas carbohydrate rich foods
like corn produce less methane.
But the goal here isn't to completely change
the diet of all of these cows
that we're feeding.
We can just tweak it a little.
We've been doing a lot of work
on feed additives
to try to reduce synthetic
methane emissions.
Ermias Kebreab is the associate dean
at UC Davis
in the College of Agriculture
and Environmental Sciences.
In 2018, he led a study that tested
how cows reacted to a certain additive...
Seaweed.
Specifically red seaweed.
Which grows naturally in tropical
and subtropical ocean regions.
Back in 2016, researchers in Australia
had found that sprinkling
the seaweed on cow feed
could potentially reduce
methane emissions by over 95%.
And in 2021, Kebreab and his team were able
to replicate the study in live animals in California.
That completely blew my mind
when I saw how effective it was.
The final results found that
the seaweed could reduce
methane emissions by 82%.
At first I couldn't believe it because I...
I've never seen anything like that before.
And this specific species of red seaweed contains
high amounts of a compound
called bromoform.
When a cow ingests it
it suppresses the enzyme
that makes methane.
And the cows
they don't even notice the change
in their dinners.
The seaweed is dried
and sprinkled onto the food
they're used to.
They can still get all the nutrients they need.
Produce milk and grow.
But the waste is reduced.
Other additives work too,
like fatty acids
which reduce methane by lowering
the carbohydrate content
and reducing a specific parasite in the rumen
known as protozoa.
And oregano was found to reduce
the number of bacteria in the rumen
to limit methane production.
But so far, out of all the additives tested
seaweed has been the most effective.
The best news is that scaling up
the growth of seaweed
doesn’t technically drain
other resources
like fresh water or fertilizer...
since we can grow it in the ocean.
Growing seaweed could also
combat other issues
like ocean acidification...
another climate problem caused by
rising levels of carbon dioxide.
But there's still a lot of research left to do...
including figuring out how to
dry it and package it
and ship it at a low cost.
Like, how do we effectively
get seaweed
from a subtropical area
to, say... Maine...
without adding tons of emissions
with shipping?
That is, if you didn't know that seaweed
is super heavy when wet.
But once we figure out the logistics,
it's over.
We solved it.
The cows are content and
the planet is saved.
Except not at all, obviously.
For one, this doesn't appear to be
a one size fits all solution.
Recently, another Australian study
found that the same red seaweed only cut
methane emissions by under 30%.
Now, granted, that's still a reduction,
which is good news
but may be less of a miracle
than we hoped.
Others are urging researchers
to slow down on red seaweed
because of the bromoform .
In it’s pure form,
the EPA has reported
that it could be dangerous
to human health
if ingested.
Luckily, studies so far haven't found
that at dangerous levels in milk
or in meat from cows eating
the seaweed additive.
But studies still need to be done
on how it might affect
the cows long term.
So it's not a silver bullet...
but thankfully seaweed’s
not our only option.
I think this is just one of several solutions
that are being looked at
at the moment.
And overall, there's a big push for change.
In 2021, 150 countries,
including the United States
signed the United Nations
Global Methane Pledge...
which aims to reduce methane emissions
by 30% by 2030.
It's becoming more and more clear now
that we won't get there...
unless we tackle enteric
methane emissions.
In an ideal world,
we'd have less livestock.
But getting people to change their habits
isn't always the most straightforward
or quickest solution.
The work of searching for solutions
to the climate crisis
needs to be multifaceted.
Within a year or two,
you will see quite
a lot of different activities
and different solutions.
That's going to come up.
And that could be one less
cow burp at a time.